howdy gamers welcome to our
pre-launch live stream of the legend of
zelda skyward sword hd
we'll be playing the game for about 40
minutes i'm gonna try my best to get
through the skyview temple in that time
i am joined by my good pal kurt indivina
will be reading the chat if you guys
have any questions about this game
drop in chat i've completed the game
myself so
um i'm allowed to talk about anything
except for the final dungeon and beyond
so anything before that
happy to answer questions happen to show
you anything you'd like to see
uh so with that out of the way let's
just get right into it kurt
start the timer hi timer started we're
in 40 minutes
uh so before we get in i uh there were
some questions in chat uh
about the amiibo functionality so
unfortunately we did not have access
to the zeldin laughing amiibo before
release but i brought
some amiibo figures with me i have the
skyward sword link so i thought i'd show
off how that works so
first of all you have to enable amiibo
in the settings
um which i do have it's off by default
and you can't use amiibo until you first
enter fair and woods and then you can
summon phi
and you can click use amiibo and then i
will
i will scan i don't know if you can see
this i will scan the skyward sword
amiibo
only for fire to say master i'm afraid
that amiibo accessory is not one that i
can recognize
and that's the end of that so the only
amiibo that works in the game
is the new zealand lofting amiibo which
i do not have uh every other amiibo is
the same
i i have some more but let's just get
going because we only have 40 minutes
dude we also i mean the we have
already lots of questions in chat so go
forward go for it
okay so first off i'm gonna start with
twitch and i'm gonna go over to you
youtube folks don't you worry
uh somebody in twitch is asking does the
hd version still have that game crashing
song of hero bug that was in the wii
version
i am not sure if it does uh i did when i
did the song of hero i did it the
i guess the way it's kind of recommended
to do it where you would do
baron woods then elder volcano and then
linear desert because originally for
those who don't know there was a bug
where i think if you talk to the goron i
forgot his name
in the lid neru desert it would like
crash your game i'm not sure if it's
there i doubt it is
um but i have not tested myself i mean
we are with
the mr we we were with game spots
mr nintendo zelda expert himself
evan langer uh so he would know more
than
anybody else would know look at that
damn outfit i'm bra
i feel like i'm playing with link but
he's talking and he has a beard and it's
weird but
so i mean still that's a huge honor
this is a this is an outfit from when i
was a kid it barely fits me anymore you
only see the top but it barely fits me
on the bottom
uh shout out to my friend as a child's
mother robin caesar for making me this
and shout out to my own mother for
making this hat
so yes dude uh
both those people mrs langer you're
great anyways uh we have some other
questions i want to get to
in youtube chat we have a lot of things
coming up so i apologize folks i am
getting there as fast as i can so um
what do we got oh so talk about controls
evan
um people wanna know if you're playing
um with button only controls right now
how to control the camera so they want
to know how to control the camera with
uh button-only controls
sure so let me let me demonstrate that
right now so
if you use the right stick um you
control the sword
now if you hold the l button you'll see
this little prompt right here that says
use r to look and then you can move the
camera
so you can move the sword and then
move the camera so if you're playing
with the motion controls
you just use the right stick to move the
camera while link swings the sword
um but here you have to kind of do one
or the other but i think it actually
it actually works pretty seamlessly so
like for example i'm moving
and then i'm like oh there's or here i
can i can go to that enemy in the other
room
so sweet
uh man so somebody else wants to know
can you play left-handed
and can link go lefty like he's supposed
to uh no unfortunately link keeps his
sword
in the right hand you can't play with
the body controls um but yeah
discriminating
unfortunately you can't switch yeah uh
man people are so i'm having trouble
keeping up okay so in the game
uh spot trailers chat we have somebody
as the game running at 4k
60 frames per second or 1080p 60 frames
per second i'm pretty sure that's 1080p
at 60 correct
right so for this stream there's no 4k
this street this stream specifically the
windows in 720p but yes the game goes up
to 1080p
um finally motion controls aren't needed
thank god anthony beltran says hey man
but at least it's there for those who
want it
but this is just time um
toilet princess what do we got somebody
says no no please give us twilight
princess majority ask
ask majora's mask crayons time
wind waker i agree with you dude like of
course i can't give you those things but
i uh i agree
wholeheartedly that we should have the
ability to
play those how our heart desires but you
know what nintendo does exactly what
nintendo
ninten don't as evan has put it um
what do we got nintendo don't
want to put those games on it um
how did you get it early well uh we're
game spot where
uh it is for review preview uh press
purposes that's why evan langer he's the
video man who handled all that he's got
a bunch of video content in fact we have
what we got
10 minutes of uh original and remastered
to check out some comparisons there um
what else you got going on evan what are
you working on yeah there's so there's
the
we have the graphics comparison up on
our main gamespot channel
um hold on i wanna i wanna get oh i got
hit
i wanna get this guy the shield
bashing's a lot easier in this game with
the button controls but anyways yeah we
have the graphics comparison that i did
with the wii and the switch version we
have our video review that was written
by
kevin kenizevic and it was edited by
richard lee
uh you can also check out 10 minutes of
gameplay on our trailers channel which
is our second channel
um and then there's this that you're
watching right now and i'm also working
on a video about the biggest
and smallest changes between the two
versions so that should be up hopefully
by the end of the week
we also have uh a question about whether
or not hero mode is available from the
start of the game
no unfortunately hero mode is not it's
the same as the original
gotta unlock it
[Music]
good for you i hear that a little chest
sound
oh yeah i was skipping the dialogue i
don't need to give the dialogue
master i have information for you you
have obtained a map of this area you
could view it by pressing minus
not supposed to talk evan you don't need
the you don't need to do it oh sorry
um i will mention though uh phi
still is doing obvious things in this
game
i don't think it's completely removed as
some people might have assumed
it was there are answers before there
are instances where it's removed
i think personally i counted 17
instances where there were dialogue
changes or she didn't pop up anymore
oh wow okay 17 damn but there's still a
bunch like
like this one
yeah personally i don't really hate i
didn't hate motion controls i'm one of
those
one of those uh those dudes who like got
a lot of enjoyment um
sitting back and swinging my arms around
like a fool
but um so i also like when they did
super mario galaxy
uh also like on the switch all-stars i
like
i actually think i prefer playing that
game of motion controls
uh whitney your meeting got canceled
congratulations you can hang out with us
a whole lot longer
down with work uh in games about
trailers chat any other new features
that have
not been officially announced by
nintendo um
in terms of features i can't think of
anything off top in my head
but there are little things like for
example in the original game
one of the first things you can do is
you can save this this
cat like creature named mia and if you
return it uh
originally the person asking would just
be like thanks but now they give you 20
rupees for doing it so they're little
things like that
um but uh the big oh and um in the
original game there were these like
there was the sheikah stone
that you got towards the beginning of
the game where you can go back to it and
show you video hints of like what to do
that has been completely removed from
the game so no more video hints you just
i guess they're really leaning into you
figuring out yourself now um instead of
them telling you what to do
um there might be more but those are the
ones i could just think of off top of my
head
uh i have no idea how to say this name
emesis man
emesis men um i'm sorry
uh for screwing your name up in the game
spot trailers chat but he is using
button controls
uh for this for this thing for this
current playthrough
we're doing now so you can see right
here it says a to leap
in the original game with the motion
controls and if you use the motion
controls on the switch you have to shake
the controller to leap around so
now you can just use a which is much
nicer in my opinion
[Music]
anyways good to do so somebody in the
twitch chat
uh my jinx 07 is here mode available at
the start unfortunately that's not it is
the same as the other one
you gotta you gotta beat the game right
is that how you get it evan
got to beat the game to become a true
hero even in a game that's
from 2011.
yes november 20th i believe that what
happened what like what like how
what anyways um i know yeah if any folks
in chat have
played this game and it came out let me
know you'll show your age
um i did i played it when it came out
you
yours your agent you look at you look
you're
um how old you you were like 12.
i was 13. i was 13 when that game came
out yeah
is this compatible with the pro
controller yes it is playing with bro
with it he's doing it evan evan link
langer
um
somebody wants to know what is your
favorite mario and luigi game is it
mario and luigi combined
or just like mario game or luigi game
because my favorite
my favorite mario game is mario odyssey
my favorite luigi game is probably the
original luigi's mansion if i had to go
separate
so what about what about you what about
you kirk
um well maybe dude
super mario 3d land for the 3ds is like
hands down
one of the greatest games i've ever
played in my entire life i think it is
i think it's so good it i absolutely
love that game
that's my favorite mario game then
probably mario uh super mario brothers 3
after that
otherwise it's luigi's mansion one
no two i like two a lot people hate on
two but i think two is pretty amazing
um i was maybe gonna say three but i
just i feel like the original has such a
mood like such an atmosphere that was
never replicated in the in the sequels
so we got another we got sammy tvs
asking how to control
the camera again um if i remember this
right evan you hold the trigger down
correct
yes you hold uh you use the right stick
to move to move the sword and the camera
but you you hold the l button when you
want to move the camera here
i can i'll wait for this cutscene to end
but i could do it again real quick
um lots of questions about how you move
the camera i mean that's
understandable so you can do that before
right so if you if you hold
so if you move the right stick you're
just moving the sword if you hold the l
button so not zl but the l button
then you'll see this little prompt here
that says look and then you can use the
right stick to move the camera so
for example you're running you're moving
the camera then like oh there's an enemy
i'm gonna swing my sword i'm gonna
defeat them i'm gonna be the hero of the
skies
um is there hd rumble did you notice
that at all
somebody asked that yeah there's a
little bit of hd rumble um
uh it's here maybe
i'll uh like let's see if there's any
right here
no there's no hd rumble for this there's
a little there's a little bit there's
not a lot
but there's a there's a little bit uh
whitney just wants to know how the
controller feel how the pro controller
feels
tell me about its texture does it feel
like does the texture of the controller
feel good
if it's a very ergonomic design as they
say
only true gamers use the pro controller
um okay you've got these let's not have
that conversation
give us your review of the pro
controller just show us what it looks
like you like it
yeah i love the project this is my pro
controller that i got uh the data switch
came out
i still use it still works fine it's got
really good battery life which i like a
lot
it's got nice big buttons which are good
um for this game it's really nice i like
the button controls in this game a lot i
think they work really well
um but i know uh our review on game spot
by kevin he was not a big fan of
button controls so i mean that's why we
that's why we get
uh a little you know at least there's
options
um absolutely
hey what's your feeling um what's your
feeling on spirit tracks evan
i love spirit tracks i love the dsl the
games i think spirit tracks is better
than hourglass
i've always really enjoyed that game
soundtrack's great um i like that you
can
kind of play a zelda when you have her
control those
uh forget the name of those things that
you can have her control like those
soldier type things um spirit track is
good um better than hourglass
and i would recommend it uh
also let's actually give whitney what
she asked like how do you feel about
you know also there's something twitch
asking kind of the same thing is um
our button
how are our button non-motion controls
button controls are they responsive like
how does it feel like how does it
get okay yeah yeah i think they're great
uh let me get these rupees real quick so
they don't disappear but
i think they're really really good um
the right stick is used to control the
sword
um as it was like with the motion
controls you go like up left
down you can also make it like this so
link can kind of
point at you so it's like hey look at
you pale
um he looks like he doesn't make eye
contact with you though
no i don't like he doesn't like that i'm
imitating him um
but yeah i think those those are really
good uh the rest of the controls
you know left stick to move uh zr does
all the buttons there's there's gyro as
well if you'd like for some of this
stuff
um and yeah you can move the camera
which i think is an amazing addition and
i think holding the l button is really
clever because the
l button isn't really used for anything
here i could show you um
here's a screen of the of the controls
for you um
so yeah you click in the r button to
thrust which is great i never liked
doing that with the wii remote where you
had to thrust forward
uh you click in the left stick to do a
shield bash which makes it a lot easier
to do
um yeah l plus rs look around you you
do the r button to open the pouch which
was the same as the minus button on the
wii remote
um and then like i said earlier when
you're climbing vines you don't like
shake the remote you can just hit the a
button and link
will keep leaping i think they're really
good i think they're done really well
and i think you know skyward sword at
its core is built as a motion controls
game there's no getting around that
so i think the butt controls are a great
workaround and i think they work really
well and for me personally
i'm more inclined to go back to this
game again with the button controls than
ever was being like oh i gotta set up
the sensor bar and i gotta
with the whole thing with the weir mode
and i gotta shimmy around kurt you said
you liked it which is
awesome but um for me it was like just
never my thing
i mean i i think for what it's worth
like i think that's the thing about
motion controls of the switch
is that you don't need anything other
than a joy con
which is you know relieving it made it
made playing a game like mario odyssey
again i'm sorry mario galaxy again
um like exciting and like i still have
that nostalgic feeling without having to
set up my wii and
motion bar and all that jazz uh
you also had to buy i have it right here
the wii motion plus
controller and i didn't own that so i
bought this when it came out
but like if you didn't have that you
couldn't even play the game you needed
wii motion plus
um we got going on
evan how do you feel do you think you're
gonna be able to do this in 40 minutes
we got
24 minutes left yeah i think i'll be
okay
really damn that's because you're right
gear of him is very easy with the butt
because gearhem is the boss fight in
this in this dungeon he's very easy
with uh button controls so i'm not too
worried about that boss fight
also although i i guess i've been kind
of skipping the dialogue but i think
that dialogue i'll i'll just kind of let
go because i think that's good
it's fine i mean people will have their
chance to get all in the nitty-gritty of
the dialogue when the game comes out
on friday so uh um
we're here to we're here to see how it
controls how it feels how it looks
and whether or not mr nintendo zelda
expert langer
can get through this in 40 minutes while
asking while answering questions so if
anybody has any more questions please
hit us up in chat
while you're at it let me know whether
or not
you like
zelda zelda
zelda fan says i love this game
i'm glad zelda i'm glad zelda fan loves
this game
yeah um i could have sworn you would
have been a metroid zelda fan but you
know
that's how it goes let's see
to do i mean you're zelda fan for life
but that doesn't mean you love all of
them
that's true i hate triforce heroes bam
there it is
waiting hot
otherwise so where are you at what are
you doing now
so uh right now i'm trying to get a i
believe a key
um a little earlier i got a piece of
heart so now i have seven heart
containers instead of
uh six because i had three ahead of time
oh and uh
for anyone curious about the the butt
controls as well i forgot to mention
this um to do a fatal blow
you have to use the controls to go up
down up really quickly
and if you want to do a spin attack
you'd do left right left really quickly
so that's how that works instead of
having
that that does sound i gotta see i got
to play it and see how that feels
because that does seem a little
wonky hearing it yeah it is
um sometimes it's not always the most
responsive and i would admit that's
probably the weakest part of the button
controls but again i think
a workaround for for trying to
substitute what the motion controls are
doing i think it's
the best they probably could do
man i can't wait to play triforce heroes
hd remaster
see i would actually want that because
the big problem with that game was it
was designed for three people
and the only way to properly play that
game with three people is have three
3ds's and three copies of the game and
everyone in the same room
you could technically do online play but
there was no voice chat or anything
so if you were playing with random
people you wouldn't be able to
communicate it's a game all about
communication working together
and unfortunately as a i believe i was
17 when that game came out so as a
teenage right now i don't know a lot of
friends that were playing 3ds games
uh and lived near me that wanted to play
triforce hero so i played that game
single player and unlike four swords
adventures
um triforce heroes was not designed well
for single player where four swords
adventure was
so uh i had a horrible time with that
game single player but if they redid it
for switch and they matted like proper
online functionality with like voice
chat and stuff or i guess i could just
talk to people on the internet now or
talk through discord or whatever
um i would totally be on the internet
yeah
uh cheesy mcneesy wants to know what
your favorite dungeon in the game is
that is a tough one i i think i'm gonna
go with
the ancient cistern only because i love
that boss fight with that guy with the
with all the arms and you gotta like
whip his arms off if you remember that
one
it's so i think i remember i remember
like legitimately getting giddy during
that fight like i
remember like like having a moment where
like yeah i think that was amazing yeah
so
i'm going to say that dungeon
specifically for that reason
um but yeah it's tough because a lot of
the dungeons in this game are really
good
but i think the boss fights are a little
weak like you fight fury him twice and
stuff so
agent sister and that's my answer
for those asking if you think i mean
uh somebody's like do you think nintendo
will remake oracle seasons and age of
spirit tracks
i mean like we can't say i guess uh it's
a pipe dream
i would say for like all things we want
from nintendo
yeah i mean i love the lynx awakening
remake and if they did that
exact same thing for the oracle games i
would completely be on board with that
um so hopefully that happens
hmm how are the motions we got a lot of
people i mean
for folks who are just coming in cool
cats thank you for being here thanks for
tuning in and uh hanging with us
mr nintendo expert zelda man himself
evan langer and myself curtin davina
um for those of you who don't know we're
playing with button controls he's going
to be he's playing on the pro controller
as we speak
i think i lost kurt it's okay he'll come
back
so anyways playing through the dungeon
uh we got the spider
which i'm going to uh push through the
hole in the in the floor
so they're gone now um
[Music]
and uh
[Music]
i'm gonna open this door so i can get
back if i'd like to
um
[Music]
and there's this guy who's gonna
try to come after me but i have a little
trick
make sure that he won't bother me or us
[Music]
so how you guys doing uh i don't have
the chat open unfortunately um so
hopefully the issue with kurt will be
resolved in a second and he'll be back
and we can get back to our regularly
scheduled
programming we're on our regular
schedule programming you know how it
goes
um
[Music]
[Music]
uh yes so uh so here's another example
of a change in this game with the button
controls you use the
the r button to swing the controller so
you can swing
forwards and backwards um
so you could jump like that so instead
of having to shake the wii remote or the
joy
con like you were in the original game
you can do that now
cool uh hi john luke producer here
uh
that his internet straight up went out
and he is currently working on it
got it no worries i appreciate the
update i will i will keep things going
in the meantime let me uh
i can't let me pull up i was gonna say i
could pull up the chat and read first
okay yeah
cool john luke is filling in for kurt in
the moment so yeah let me know uh
kurt i'm not sure where he left off
uh oh whoops let's see if there are any
other
questions or things people have in the
chat
let me turn my ac off all good
okay uh so let's see
uh cheesy mcneesy wants to know what
your favorite dungeon is in the game
i did answer that sorry yes the answer
is ancient cistern with the
i believe the boss is collactos with all
the arms and
he had to whip his arms off very good
one yeah
um
let's see
uh okay so emma wants to know i'm not
sure if this has already been asked but
what would you say is your least
favorite thing about skyward sword
uh whether it's uh
[Music]
the we were actually talking about this
right before the stream started um
when you have to do that whole song of
the hero thing um
towards the end of the game and you have
to go back to all three areas and you
have to like
swim underwater to get all the music
notes for one of them and then when you
go to elder volcano you lose all your
items and you have to get them back
i did not particularly like either of
those i did like the last part of that
section with the
with the desert dragon la neru and um
how he has that whole challenge
afterwards where you can re-fight the
bosses i think that one's cool
um whoops but uh yeah those first two
parts i think
are a little bit like all right let's
let's keep the game moving
um but yeah i would say that's probably
my least favorite part if i think of one
thought might have
uh yeah apparently they just kurt just
straight up lost internet
that's unfortunate i'm sorry to hear
that kurt but i appreciate you helping
out as much as you did
um and it's completely not your fault
believe i got all the treasure yes i did
trials of working from home
yeah unfortunately um i just saw him
move for a sec
oh is he coming back maybe oh it's back
he says he's back
perfect um the other thing if you just
saw
uh with the button controls now to open
the the door you use the left and right
stick
uh to move it around instead of the
motion controls and then you click in
the left and right stick at the same
time to push the key
in the door so um that's how
that works um instead of the motion
control so here's a great cutscene
uh where we meet one of the main
antagonists of the game
um hi can you hear me yes are you back
yes yes i am so
sorry my dear oh beautiful friends
the i like the modem just stopped the
air nothing was working
it was the zelda spirits were too strong
oh
that was such a travesty i can't believe
this happened but we're back
i'm so excited to be back hi folks i
hope you're all doing well did i miss
anything really special
um no uh john luke filled in for a
minute to ask some questions which was
nice
uh you missed me putting the key in the
door um you missed me getting the lost
key but no you didn't miss anything
totally not your fault
and i'm glad you're back yes yes yes yes
all right uh we are a professional
company however i am at home
deal with it um that's the nature of how
it goes
so man this is great we still have 13
minutes left
evan is on track to finish this i got
lost in the in the the abyss of the
internet and now i'm back
um thanks folks i'm really happy to be
here
round of applause alberto thank you
thank you thank you
okay um
oh and by the way you can skip cutscenes
now in the original game so if you just
hit the minus button you get a little
prompt
uh which is only available in hero mode
in the original wii version of the game
so no no wants to know yo kurt how do
y'all feel about the loftwing amiibo
where well unfortunately i don't think
either one of us have it yet um i'm
looking forward to it i pre-ordered it
but unfortunately i don't have it yet
yeah how do you feel about the um the
feature you get with it
i don't like that it's locked behind a
25 plastic figurine
um yeah i think it's a cool feature
nonetheless um but yeah
hmm dude i love this villain i think
he's incredible
um he's so he's yeah he's so eccentric
oh look at him so romantic here's a
here's
everyone's favorite part it's just one
of those like he's like
it makes him extra creepy because he
likes to get up close and personal
yeah there it is um yeah i love when
zelda games deviate from ganon
i think that's always uh i think that's
that always pays off for them like
majora and majora's mask
or um gear him for skyward sword or
zan for um twilight princess yes
yes also uh code zero says
am i the only one who liked most
commotion trolls lol
no code zero you're not the only one i
dug motion controls
i'm a fan um say what you will
everyone has their place but that's why
this one is exciting because it's got
options
you can play how your heart desires yeah
that's definitely the it's not like they
remove the motion controls
you could use both which i think is
great my preference is button controls
kurtz maybe preferences motion controls
perfect i mean i'll probably definitely
be playing with button controls
uh wow you're turning back on the motion
hold on no no no no no no what i'm
trying to say is like there's like again
you know it's like depending on my move
like when i if i'm gonna play this thing
handheld it's gonna be button controls
but if i'm gonna dock it i would
probably you know
maybe consider it we'll see i have to
get my hands on a thing i haven't played
it yet it's all right
um okay
ever anyway how's everybody doing how's
everyone been since i was gone
for a brief moment in time what a
terrible terrible moment
it's all good that's that's how it goes
also i want to give a personal thank you
and shout out
to jean-luc the man the creature
who is not seen but is helping this
happen and also was able to step in
uh when i went mia so jean-luc thank you
uh for everything you do yes thank you
so much john luke for doing that and for
running this stream and for
helping me plan this stream and doing
tests with me and everything like that
which alberto diaz wants to know which
zelda game do lily and megatron like
best
um i think
i think megatron and for those in chat
i'm talking these are my cats lily and
megatron are my cats
uh megatron who's asleep you can't see
her oh you kid's gotta see her
there she is megatron who's asleep um i
get the impression that she's like
she's a spooky mystical creature i think
she's i think her favorite would be
majora's mask um
lily on the other hand is a bright
colorful
loving obnoxious beautiful creature
um i think she'd be into
either uh wind waker
or um
oh do we lose card again we lost kurt
again
we'll never know okay we'll never know
what another game the league
wait no you're back i'm back what what's
lily's favorite
you'll never know you'll never know
you'll never know i can't believe this
is happening i have decent internet
it's okay whatever how it goes don't
worry about it okay it's fine
um nobody will know what lily's favorite
is i'm sorry alberto diaz
i'm not gonna turn back time to let you
know just let him know just let it be
known
it's a mystery um because lily is a
mystery
[Music]
perfect but emma emma wagner really
wants to know
i don't know you'll have to lily where
is she lily
now we definitely won't know uh
well every time see that's the curse
right we want to know what lily's
favorite
uh zelda game is and she just cuts off
the internet okay so what are you gonna
do
you can't you can't ever ask about lily
yeah
yeah stop please in chat stop asking
about lily's favorite uh
zelda game uh it'll you'll destroy
kurt's internet thank you
just kidding um anyways i just got a
goddess cube which is hiding back here
uh after you finish the temple so make
sure
you get that um and then uh i don't know
how much time we have left because
kurt is running the timer uh i i we have
about
uh eight seven eight minutes cool oh
you're back
are you back i see you yes we can't talk
about my cats anymore
yeah um unfortunately that's the all
right that's the curse so you're at the
eight
minute mark um cool
okay here we are anyway this is the end
i finished this is the last this is the
cutscene wow that ends up
quick thanks where's lily
lily's the one cutting off your internet
yeah
uh it's fine a lot of people in chat say
i blame lily and you know what i
say that for everything and i love i
love that cat but i blame lily for
everything
um
[Music]
any other uh questions in the last few
minutes just a lot of people upset that
i
or a lot of people talk about plot twist
with lily plot twist lily is chewing on
his internet fiber cables
she would um she she was on my hard
drives and i absolutely lose my mind
[Music]
uh i typoed in chat and i actually said
i'm mac so that's it i'm knack
and that killed it too you know how it
goes uh knack
uh don't say lily don't say nak these
are the uh
the words uh
but it's cool we are coming up towards
the end here
we got the uh ruby tablet so now we can
go to elden volcano but we're not gonna
do that here unfortunately
um here's phi telling us uh it would
appear that
zelda purified herself in the waters of
this spring
i calculate a 97 percent chance that she
has already set out for eldon where
another great spring exists
however it is not clear what method of
travel zlata used to move from here to
her next destination
my analysis suggests you should take the
tablet to the altar in skyloft
obvious information doing so will likely
open a new column of light on the
surface allowing you to send another
area and continue search for zelda so
here's the thing about phi
if you think about it her sole purpose
like the reason
that they were created was to guide link
so if i were phi of course i would just
be in his face like hey
like i'm going to be really obvious and
really blunt with you because i don't
want you to mess
up and make the world um disappear so
that's how i feel about it oh so here's
another interesting change in the game
in the original wii version after that
cutscene it would prompt you do you want
to save
before moving on now because skyward
sword hd has auto save
you do not actually have to that prompt
doesn't happen at all in the game
anymore it will just automatically save
to keep the pace moving so
i'm sure speed runs will be into that um
and i just think like i said it just
keeps the pace moving so you have an
auto save for this stuff now too
um hey are you back
yeah what's that what's the time rat
um you have five minutes
okay uh i guess i could do a little bit
more um because we're kind of done with
the skype temple i could just go fly
around in the sky for a few minutes
uh anyways i'm glad you're back i'm not
allowed to stream anymore
you that i need to call comcast i need
to like be like we need to chat like we
need to see what is up
um homie don't play this
i ain't dealing with this i'm sorry you
are dealing with it
barely um he's knack i'm knack everybody
um skyward sword hd is actually knack
three i don't know if you guys knew that
let's see what we got shaken and [ __ ]
chaturao my cool cat
dudes um
unfortunate freeze frame from kurt i
wonder how sick i looked
um oh oh comcast no wonder yeah i know
punch myself in the face anyways we're
not here to talk bad about
internet providers we're here to talk
about the real
life experience of skyward sword
hd um
what it is
uh somebody wants to know does the 60
frames per second help for the motion
controls
um i haven't played motion controls too
too much admittedly i've dabbled with it
a little bit
um i think the mo the 60fps definitely
helps the overall experience it
definitely feels a lot smoother but
i think the motion controls actually
feel a little similar um and
unfortunately because there's no sensor
bar like the wii remote you have to kind
of constantly calibrate the joy con
um here's a question um
how does it feel handheld uh
it feels good uh i think you know uh i
know this is such a common complaint but
like the joycons are a little small um
and i think that if you're trying to
like move the right stick a lot
your hands are so close um it's not i
think after a while
your thumb might hurt um but uh i think
it's doable i definitely
i want to try the game in handheld more
i played a little bit in handheld um
because i've been capturing the footage
for our videos so i've had to play it
docked
uh but i tried a teeny bit and uh i
could see it maybe getting on your thumb
a little bit after a while to keep
constantly moving the right stick and
holy mail button if you're trying to
move the camera and stuff
we got uh somebody asked me a question
if i'm looking forward to collecting the
tears you know what i don't think the
tears are so bad i think the music notes
are are what kind of are what is really
tedious if you remember that
i was talking about this before we
started the stream that's like
the main point of that game which i was
like this is a bit this is a bit
annoying um
yeah um while you were away someone
asked what my least favorite part of the
game was after what my favorite
dungeon was and i mentioned that as well
i know i also the
the tears never really bothered me i
kind of like it it's like a little
stealth mission you know
i don't mind the tears but the the music
notes is like i always think of that
being
um yeah the the thing that
annoyed me the most um
all right let's see what we got going on
are you using a pro controller jason
yes evan is playing with a pro
controller
it's he's he's flipping he's he's
diddling the thumb stick that's how he's
doing the sword um
is flying uh with the loft wings better
so that's a question from whibney and we
also have that question
in twitch chat as well how are the loft
flying controls
how much time do i have like a minute oh
schneider's
you have a minute and a half okay let me
do the loft wing and
then i'll call it here so the loft wing
now controls with the left stick on the
button controls which is much nicer
um in the wii version and if you're
doing motion controls you have to point
at it and you have to shake
to uh flap up but now you have to hit a
much nicer just gotta just kind of smack
the a button and i feel like it's more
precise you could do stuff like this
um just like up and down you could
shimmy up and down um and then it's the
x button
to use the uh little dash
things on the bottom and then it's b you
hold b to slow down which is the same as
the wii with that back b button
but uh yeah off wing i think is a lot a
lot nicer to control now with the button
control for sure
uh we've got ricky spider k
can you move the camera in hd yes you
can uh
i don't know if you demonstrate this on
if you can demonstrate this while flying
but if you hold the trigger down you're
able to then
move the camera freely um does the game
have free camera with no motion controls
yes that's what we're talking about
right now
so i can't do it while i'm flying but
you can see here look around l plus r
that's how you do it the l buttons
what's the r button right stick
thank goodness um all right is that
is that time here uh you got 20 seconds
all right 20 seconds let's go let's fly
around
go to the lumpy lumpy pumpkin i don't
think i can make it there in 20 seconds
do it you have 13 seconds go to the
lumber okay it's right there you can see
it that little island
all right hold on five
four three two one
all right that's it all right and we
have wrapped it up
look at look at you evan you look
incredible you look fantastic i like
outfit i wanted to dress up you know i
figured hey we're streaming we're having
fun we're having a good time i should
have dressed up like what's
his face with the tongue i should have
like i'll gear him
yes that would have been funny i didn't
tell you about this i thought i'd
surprise
you with this as well as the audience oh
my god it was absolutely amazing
i should have dyed my hair white and got
a really big collar caller
um yeah anyways
uh hey everybody who's watching who's
just tuning in we just got done playing
the legend of zelda the skyward sword hd
uh we only have 40 minutes to be able to
spend some time with it but the game
comes out on friday
and um a review is up by our very own
kevin kenizevic you can check that out
at gamespot.com
also evan langer mr nintendo zelda
expert himself has done a ton of content
so plug that content while you're here
sure yeah so we did a i did i should say
i did a graphics comparison
of the wii in the switch version uh the
wii version running on wii u
uh 10 minutes of gameplay within the
skyview temple which you also just saw
um i did uh we just did this live stream
which will be a lot of audited so you
can watch this later if you'd like you
can
you can see me cut out six times yes you
can watch that again
and i'm also working on a video about
the biggest changes between the two
versions which i'm currently writing and
hopefully i'll be up by the end of the
week
and that's all i have to plug if you
would like to see more skyward sword
content let us know
uh now that we have our hands on the
game after all those videos are done
we could potentially make more so let us
know um if you want to see kurt's cats
play
skyward sword hd let us know that as
well we could try to make that happen
uh is that megatron yeah yeah look at
that eggplant she looks like a lumpy
pumpkin she is the lumpy pumpkin when
you fly
i'm gonna go zoop it on my loft wing and
and take a seat the lumpy
pumpkin on my bed look at this
if you want to see megatron be the lumpy
pumpkin let us know
and we'll make it here you don't even
need to say let us know just look
yeah we're introducing the one we're
already giving people
what they want oh here we
[Laughter]
and with go lumpy pumpkin
[Laughter]
for those just tuning in welcome to uh
the lumpy pumpkin
um game spot special is she breathing
yeah she's breathing she's good okay
that's good i'm glad you hear that you
just get real close with my face now
hey how's it going um
anyways how's everybody doing are you
guys looking forward to um
hanging out with a lumpy pumpkin on
friday um
when's when's the when's all the embargo
jibber jabber like we have this embargo
when's some videos going up evan
can we are those already on game spot
yeah uh
all of them that i listed except for the
biggest changes um
that i mentioned i'm still writing all
that's up right now uh graphics
comparison video review
yeah the review you want read our review
on the website you watch our video
review or graphics comparison
on this channel your i guess gamespot
youtube channel
little gamespot trailer if it's our
second channel you can check out the
gameplay clip
i'm working on biggest changes which
will hopefully go by the end of the week
but everything else i listed
you watch right now um ahead of uh
launch which is cool um
yeah the game releases on friday
alongside the game there's the
zelda and laflin amiibo as we mentioned
there's also the little master sword and
hylian
shield joycons that they're releasing um
i think they're sold out everywhere but
uh maybe there'll be something you got
one
you bought it yeah well you know how it
goes you gotta turn on wario 64 twitter
notifications after a nintendo
announcement to make sure
you get those pre-orders because
otherwise you're screwed or you gotta
camp out
uh at a store in the morning of but uh
you know i don't know if i could be like
hey
i know i work for a game spot but can i
take off work to go stand in front of a
store for many hours and try to get an
item
it's still a job at the end of the day
you still got to take a take off a
little work
you got to lose a dollar too to be able
to make you know to spend money on the
things that are true value to you like
waiting and right
i was just let's say i don't i don't
know if i want to use my time off to
stand in front of a best buy for a bunch
of hours to get some
zelda controllers i'll be honest with
you
um what else we got also i guess while
your folks are here there's a
renharasaki in chat if you don't know
who he is
he is the other uh zelda expert
the breath the wild expert of treasure
among the world
uh in terms of his talent and ability to
understand that game and make content
around that game so please
uh hey max hey rin harasaki thanks for
hanging out also for
new folks here uh go to our channel go
to gamespot go to youtube.com
check out all the skyward storage swords
stored
skyward sword stuff we have up on the
channel today and also while you're
there make sure to check out uh
max's phenomenal videos on a whole bunch
of crap you didn't know about breath of
the wild because it's never ending
because that game's absurd and he's
absurd he's very
talented at that game with everything
said 100 so at this point uh we could
wrap it up or if you guys have more
questions i can answer the questions
even though i'm not playing the game
oh did we
do this again we lost kurt again all
right well if we lost kurt
i guess that's where we could wrap it up
for now uh if that's
cool uh so yeah i'm gonna wrap it up
then
thank you all so much for joining uh and
watching me play the legend of zelda
skyward sword hd
if you have any additional questions you
can leave them in the comments of this
video after it becomes a vod you can go
watch any of our other videos leave
questions you could
message me on twitter if you'd like i'm
happy to answer any any and all
questions that you guys might have
uh thank you so much for watching uh
enjoy this still frame of curt
right next to me and uh yeah i will
see you guys next time thanks so much
for joining